[Music]
chili pepper is produced
all year round in ghana the crop grows
well
in every part of the region chili pepper
is currently
the most leading vegetable exported from
ghana to many parts of european
countries
such as the uk france and the
netherlands
this week on the ghanaian farmer we have
a conversation on the back
of what it takes to go into chili pepper
my name is annunam
and this is ghanaian farmer i'm going to
have a conversation
with mr john
he has about two acre chili pepper
adan east district follow our social
media platform the ghanian farmer share
your views with us
do you want to go into chili pepper what
are the questions you want to
you want answers to just ask such
questions on our social media platform
and we will be answering them this
program is probably brought to you
by lizzie to mentormix i'm going for a
quick breather
when i come back i will engage mr john
in a conversation stay tuned
[Music]
thanks for staying with us if you're
just tuning you're watching the ghanian
farmer on joy prime television my name
is anjanam
and stunning next to me is mr john
15 years
[Music]
the whole
yes
[Music]
okay for a year american thousand cities
yeah roughly
you spend more than thousands
okay okay
chili peppermint chili pepper okay
chili peppers
[Music]
um
all right so viewers you are still
watching the ghanaian farmer my name is
the show is broadly brought to you by
lizzy tomato mix
if you go to the market and you're
shopping for the kitchen
all the ingredients you buy it is
incomplete
without lazy tomato mix very affordable
and in
all shops we are going to take a quick
look at
60 seconds what is trending in
agricultural space when we come back
we will continue our conversation and
definitely i'll be taking you to the
kitchen
what can we make with chili peppers stay
tuned i'll be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks for saying gone bye was 60
seconds on our greg and you're still
watching the ghanian format today
we are focusing our attention on chile
pepe
here in adan east district and i'm
having a conversation
with john pepper no
okay great chili pepper business so
[Music]
um
and he had an interesting conversation
with me about chili pepe
a lot of value can be added to chili
pepe
here in ghana but one major thing they
lack
is access to factories or processing
plants
that can aid farmers if they are not
able to sell immediately
or go and put it in their warehouse they
can process
the raw you know pepper into powder foam
and sell we always go to buy from other
countries to come in so that is no good
as a country coming up is what can we
make with this in the kitchen what can
we make with chili pepper
me i love pepper a lot so let's go to
the kitchen and find out what a celeb
is preparing today in the kitchen thank
you so much for watching
this is ghanian farmer if you missed the
episode make sure to subscribe to our
youtube channel the ghanian farmer
share your views with us on what you
make of chile pepe
here if you want to connect to mr john
just hit me up on social media
and i'll get you connected until next
week i'll come your way again
with another farmer here in ghana
the ghanaian farmer business ceiling the
land i came with a cutlass a farming two
we go to the farm you know
to support our farmers to encourage them
of the good works they are doing
and definitely mr john will be weeding
some small small
you know weeds i see in the farm so
mr john papa
wa
so thank you so much for staying with us
next week we'll come your way again with
another interesting episode until then
it's a bye for now
[Music]
it's another exciting week on the
ghanian farmer this
is the kitchen segment that what can we
make
with this what can we make with chili
pepper
if you want your meal to be hot spicy
i encourage you to use chili pepper this
week we were all the way in our din
to feature a chili pepper farmer to get
to know more
about chili pepper farming here in ghana
my name is program is proudly brought to
you by lizzie tomato mix
yes my women and even the bachelor's
hunt i always encourage him
that when he goes to the market so that
his meal will be tasty healthy and
delicious
he should go for lizzy to mental mix if
you want to be a distributor
just call the number to speak on your
screen and they will come to your
doorstep
to give you what you want to sell so
this week i have
my own country woman in the kitchen you
know i wear girls you can never go wrong
with that are you very good at cooking
they sing well oh my goodness she's a
later sensation
here on our radio and tv stages and i'm
happy to
oh my you're welcome thank you my
goodness you're looking so
fine really even in the april yeah we're
killing it you're looking so high
so today uh we have your ingredient
right here
the rice the chicken tomato onions and
then the chili pepper
let's start off what are you cutting
first so i know what to have
okay i think i'll go first okay yes i'll
start with my
vegetables okay so whilst you're doing
that i would help you to put the rice on
fire
so how did things look for you tell me
about a little bit of all that
it wasn't easy hide and seek issues
when i was a baby and my grandmother
encouraged me
i used to live with her and she used to
sing too okay
yeah it's a family thing my mom sings so
well better than me
how is that certain level i mean the
songs you have so far
yeah it's good it's good but sometimes
people don't really pay attention
okay but i mean it's a matter of time
i'm dropping my songs i'm doing
promotion
so for how many songs do you have out
there because if i have
four official solo songs out there okay
starting from
now and then i came on after six
talk to your boyfriend and then you want
to have out which is 69 and you are
checking it out
and you know i heard someone say
look at her age and she's singing about
69. don't mind what is fine that
you know what inspired that title it's
just enough
i mean 69 when you listen to the song i
think you should have time and listen to
the song i only listen to the
brief part that i think excuse me that
part right
yes 69 is about what do you mean
i see that's interesting okay so uh
your rice water is warm now so let me
just
add my rice wow
yes
[Music]
how is the promotion of the new song
going 69 how is it going
it's okay people are vibing to it they
like it
it's advised this is not your vibe it's
not your vibe but people that love it i
love it
okay it's banging available on all
streaming platforms
i think i have to go in with my tomatoes
okay let me give you this one okay let
me give you this one my lizzy yes he
wants to mix
okay because the oil is heated okay
so thanks you're yeah me with everything
yeah i told you i like food i love that
because i'm so sweet i like food i don't
like to
make my guests so fast at the end of the
day
you will tell me and your name didn't
help me if you don't know
i don't give
ah be careful
it's hard um i have to lower the okay
the fire
this industry is a male-dominated
industry right what is the strategy to
face their boots for boots that's a
political word
yes what was the strategy i'm actually
going with a promotion i have 69 out
okay and i'm doing my media tour so you
listen to me on your head
yes i'm on girlfriend
yeah girl and i'm here so you can see
i'm going around already
and then i'll be going to kumasi too
okay for my media tour in kumasi as well
and then i'm doing it i'm promoting it
right now as promo i'm pushing the west
out there i'm trying to let people
notice or people who have not heard of
me get to know me
okay i want to get this one i think
would have to add i know
that chili pepper and all that
yeah wait to enjoy this meal
i know right ah so i have my spices up
here
my ginger onion all-purpose chia
curry powder you want to use it yeah i
want to use let me help you right
at this point we'll go for a quick
breather the kitchen is hot i'm sweating
she's sweating
[Music]
thanks for staying you're still watching
the ghanian farmer my name is
anyanam this program is finally brought
to you by lizzie tomento mix
i always encourage my fellow women the
bachelors if you go out shopping
for the market don't forget to buy your
little tomato mix
it gives your meal a great taste to make
it delicious if you want to be
a distributor just call the number
displayed on your screen make sure you
subscribe to our youtube channel
the ghanian farmer share your views with
us what are you able to make home
with chili pepe and i'm here she's not
just a sundress
she is not just a beautiful woman so as
you call yourself
she just finished preparing her rice and
has two hey
daddy yes ma'am this your fryer is
looking
really good you know
i know so at this point i guess
you are ready i'm ready have you tasted
it i've tasted this
can i also taste it oh yeah you can
you can you know but hold your breath
through because this is tasty i'm not
sure
really okay so viewers we are about to
dish out
the rice and the taste to you so that um
you you know please do the reaction
please again
[Music]
[Laughter]
um you see let me bring the walls
as well right see how i mean
i know i i can see really like my
goodness i
like my foot it's good though okay
so let me clean this for you right
um the rice's weather so kindly
give me my rice
so i love this shaped i love beautiful
food if the food is not beautiful i
can't eat it i see
yes so sweetheart what's your audition
of the food
what's the future plan how is things
looking like
for and then very intense of
music and everything very promising my
dear
okay are you i can't go for any record
label in times day
they've seen your works and they want to
sign you are you available are you open
for that if i should say
um for now i'm good okay i'm okay okay
i'm working on a lot
and then i think i'm okay for now okay
how is the support live i've not gotten
to the
the support is cool my my family is
strongly behind me wow yeah especially
my my mom and my brothers and sisters
you're making some money because yeah
yeah yeah yeah your money
is the way you say and now music is
clear anymore and now that covert is in
and you know performing yeah
programs and all that are you making
some money yeah yeah
you get money from youtube and all that
yes
yes it's getting views and then when
you're getting streams online like apple
music
okay there are some of the platforms
they pay you apple music does
yes all right so uh if um your fans
or people who have just seen you today
right right to follow you and all that
can you share your handles with us
enema music underscore underscore enemy
spells en
am and normal music together underscore
the underscore is not a dash
the one that is down the one that is
down when you
put it it goes down yes you do too that
is the double underscore the same on
twitter
facebook and our music on my youtube
please subscribe
subscribe to my youtube channel and
watch out for more content follow my ig
just let's go okay let's go let's vibe
with anna
so as we enjoy the mail right
69 is on the background okay this has
been an
amazing segment once more
you know every week i don't disappoint
you and you know
i don't feel i always come your way
something spectacular
and today and i'm just made it possible
for me so please um
that's you after the show then you talk
don't worry there's two of us
so i never said so which of the plate is
mine
i mean you anyone
you see why we are taking you right now
in the realm of the spirit
there's only those who can speak this
language
yes baby
[Music]
at this point this is my rice and
chicken
bon appetit bon appetit baby
[Music]
mhm
thank you so much for sticking and
staying with us this has been another
interesting
exciting episode with anna right here
going stream her song 69 is the current
song
on all radio and tv stations and i'm
glad to have her here
for now it is time for eating
bye bye